let's see if the scheme is this
documentary about the big n-c-double-a
bribery scandal that happened and when
it was being reported on ESPN and all
these other networks it seemed pretty
clear-cut did these coaches were getting
bribed and that's how players were going
to the universities etc and then this
documentary comes out and really exposes
at least from what I saw at the first
half correct me if I'm wrong the Federal
Bureau of Investigation the FBI the feds
kind of entrapped him in my opinion okay
entrapment and the reason I know this is
something happens because we were
talking to one of our Chapo's lawyers
for another episode earlier this week
about money laundering and just about El
Chapo [ __ ] in general and he used to
work on the Attorney General side so he
was before he was a criminal defense
attorney he was actually a prosecutor
and he saw [ __ ] that the feds and the
NYPD would do to kind of set up clients
mm-hmm right and so basically with this
Christian Dawkins guy is telling the
feds he doesn't know he's a Fed it's a
guy who's an informant right
he's telling them hey I don't want to
bribe the coaches it's stupid they have
no influence over the players I have 10
times more influence than any coach and
the FBI wants to catch the coat the FBI
sets up a system where hey Christian you
pay the coaches and then the coaches
will pay the players or whatever what
the FBI wants is a bribery scandal yes
so they create one yeah now granted
coaches and university been playing play
at paying players for years yeah so it's
not entirely untrue right what they're
like apparently if you're a kid that
comes from like an urban big city you're
getting two and fifty thousand dollars a
year right Dennis Smith jr. I think he
got quarter million to go to play South
Carolina or the [ __ ] place yeah and
he said North Carolina State yeah so
it's like all these players are getting
paid right where they're getting paid
and how they're getting paid maybe it's
from the University of maybes for one of
these handlers but they're getting paid
mm-hmm but the feds basically go we want
to get coaches paying the players these
coaches are attached the institutions
and coaches also are getting money from
these brands these sneaker brands yeah
that's a bigger fish if we just get this
Christian Dawkins guy who's this
quote-unquote low-level handler giving
money to the players a few grand here a
few grand of coaches that's not a
national story we're not breaking down
institutions it's just one actor yeah it
means nothing so they kind of make it up
they force Christian Dawkins even though
he tells them multiple times no yeah
they kind of bully him into agreeing to
pay the coaches yeah and then does he
even pay them or he just keeps the money
he keeps the money so he keeps the money
does he pay the [ __ ] coaches the
coaches but is that legal to force
someone into doing illegal activity that
they tell you they don't want to do and
have no interest in doing yeah I think
should be illegal
I think they essentially are trying to
get him on keeping their money because
he would take the money they paid him
and he would just keep it he would never
give it to a coach he just go out to the
strip club or the casino or whatever and
he kept so the money if you find this
out later in the movie when he gets
arrested they they basically bring him
into a hotel room and they play all
these recordings or whatever they're
like he's supposed to go in for a
meeting there's two feds there and then
the lady that's the undercover officer
is like we got you you can either
cooperate with us or you can call a
lawyer and then he's like let me talk to
a lawyer and then immediately they got
[ __ ] bust in with guns they
throw him in jail on some real Alec [ __ ]
the first two nights he was in Sweden
where he's in there with like he said
I'm in a prison cell and El Chapo is
upstairs that's who they got me with
that grade of criminal and he won't
snitch he's like I'm not telling on any
of these coaches they're hoping to use
him to tell on the coaches and he's got
what they got recorded phone calls of
coaches basically saying we're paying
this guy but they never actually used
the words we are paying him money so
they're trying to get him to be a CI
like you wear a wire you go and you have
other meetings with these guys get them
on tape saying you were gonna pay this
player money won or $25,000 you and
you're good and he won't do it so now
they're trying to bring him up on
something and they come up with wire
fraud I don't know what the [ __ ] that
it's they do some [ __ ] on some [ __ ]
some Al Capone Eliot Ness [ __ ] oh we
can't get him on anything like murder so
I'll get him on tax evasion it's the
same kind of thing
so this is what they do they work up the
ladder yeah they set this guy up they
basically entrap him yeah okay and it
because they know by entrapping him he
has such close proximity the coaches
that then he might flip on the coach and
yes but they have to create a crime for
him to commit yes and I'm sure that
happens a lot and dude it's [ __ ] up I
didn't know that it operated it like
this and I was talking to this lawyer
guy he said this this [ __ ] blew my
mind he was working for the for the
Bronx attorney general's office or Bronk
district attorney and he was
representing this heroin dealer yeah
low-level heroin dealer not saying it's
okay it's a shitty [ __ ] thing to do
he's representing this and there it was
like a part-time heroin dealer
he sold a little bit but it wasn't his
main thing and the informant the CI
right he's telling him every week hey we
got a few more guys downtown hey we need
a bigger quantities can you give us a
bigger crime we got like 100 guys in
town and the guy on the record taping is
saying yo please stop calling me I don't
want to do this anymore I'm out leave it
no hey it's the easiest thing in the
world it's a no-brainer literally
they're just these rich guys but I'm
done he's saying I'm done now ultimately
he makes his decision you make your
choice you have to live with your
choices but you shouldn't be tricked
into breaking the law by the law right
[Applause]